this is all going to be a like bioterror
return of ultron where he's going to
release the Ultron virus the serials
coming back and he's going to sort of
use himself as a martyr to create this
whole media narrative against spider-man
what if hellas next move is to target
the new Asgard and strike a blow in
Thor's heart these does have a new Lord
this is arrogant Myrtle Beach in 2007
okay welcome this is rogue theory I am
Phillip Molina we are talking about how
does any villain ever really go away
evidently not go back Tommy hey guys no
we're gonna talk about our favorite MCU
villains and how they might be back in
the MCU and that's not even crazy
because the MCU does bring villains back
also back with us Erik Bosse it's like
you work here thank you so much Tommy
filling in last week pleasure thank you
for having yeah I really enjoyed not
watching that episode as we spilled the
tea and you my friend that sounds hot
and scalding and then post Malone over
here Angelica tray so the trailer for
Falcon Winter Soldier came out and it
shows that Baron Zemo is back which is
great because Baron Zemo has way more
potential especially to pick up the
storylines from the comics so we also
know that Loki is getting his own show
so Loki's also back we've also seen a
trailer recent shows vulture is also
back and then just in general there's
all these villains that we have on we
never saw anybody's brains get blown out
basically right which I'm waiting Mickey
so guys I want to know previous MCU
villains that we do not have
confirmation that are coming back I want
to know how they will come back anyway I
want to know what movie they're coming
back in and I want to know how they come
back I'll start great because right now
we are still living in an age Philip
living in an age of Aquarius an age of
Ultron Avengers 2 age of Ultron was
actually more like two and a half weeks
of Ultron I've had chest colds that have
lasted longer at the age of Ultron you
should get that checked out it's not
really now especially now Tommy doctors
say all the black marks on my lungs are
good they're fighting each other and
keeping me alive
so anyway I think that Ultron even
though vision did technically him at the
end of Avengers 2 electric Boogaloo
he's still alive I think his cute little
head just floated back down to earth and
we stopped Peter Purves it's all ahead
pick up the Ultron head with the red
eyes which as we know is the symbol that
Ultron is inside that particular drone
or type of robotic body I believe that
that is currently either in a dormant
state as the is the essence of Ultron so
Ultron will return and maybe move to a
different host whether it's computer
host or possibly a human host perhaps
our Wyatt Russell's character in Falcon
in Winter Soldier will have some implant
hold on you're going real fast
yes let's slow this down so you're
saying US agent yes who we have rough
confirmation we've done a couple videos
on this is gonna be on Falcon and Winter
Soldier potentially as an alternate
person who might get the shield you're
saying is secretly being controlled by
Ultron Ultron in order to release a
nanovirus the Ultron Ultron virus thank
you we were promised an age of Ultron we
were Lois where we live with all
trumpets Gong how long is an age I was
just about to ask well you're not gonna
tell us okay if I were to guess an age
is about 10 years look I went through my
it might be a thousand years of age when
I had diamond cubic zirconia studs
through my ears and hoops in my in my
cartilage and I might for another age
and that was from age 17 to 23 I caught
a look in the mirror one day and I said
you look like an [ __ ] the mouth in
five years by vampire rules more on that
later always be vamping and vampires
rule
but yeah anyway so I think that yeah
this is all going to be a like bioterror
return of Ultron where he's going to
release the Ultron virus is it gonna be
okay it's gonna be like this you were
kind of saying like mind control so like
drones of him kind of like what he had
in age of Ultron but those are now
people or no I think the nanotech will
in fact or is gonna be that in the
comics to where they also not only
control their mind but they actually
physically start to change into kind of
robot parts yes exactly like Superman 3
a movie we all have seen many times and
think about often I watch that as a kid
it was it haunted me
yeah I thought Superman movies were
horror he's gonna come back and Falcon
the Winter Soldier okay and he's going
to end up
I mean he's more than just the virus the
guy comes back I think we're going to
end up he's going to use the mind
control with to rebuild a body like a
host for him like altered carbon like he
uses that as a skin and then he can kind
of be removed and put into other sand
posts and like you know yeah we used to
be robot drones now it's like flesh
drones
flash and then they just like keep
moving who the main host is remember
that movie with Denzel Washington yeah
and it would just past that trailer so
cool were singing yeah spoiler alert
John Goodman can always get it in the
end he's a good man that's all I know
okay one flesh tone sounds disgusting oh
yeah my grandma watches he's speaking of
bad guys you can't kill Lester owns just
walk in the hole these questions are
turning into robots or they're normal
well what Philip was companioning to my
thing was that in the comics that when
they get the Ultron virus they begin to
start having robot parts but they kind
of look like their skin gets kind of
even district 9 kind of had an element
of that yeah exactly because you could
also infect them with the nano bots and
then have like a virus in there that's
controlling them infecting the software
I don't know like is like little
microscopic flood and it turns evil
Ultron that that is the same time yes
Ultron is Tony Stark's tech right so
we're all talking about the same thing
and that's these tiny little nanotech
dancing in unison into someone's body in
a poison tango tell me your black lungs
are clearly running out of air so I'm
just gonna give you another road yes but
also I really like you know hopefully
this doesn't mess up any of your guys
theories I really like when a villain
comes back in a new way hmm and it's not
just take two on the exact same thing so
Ultron coming back in virus form and and
a combination of computer virus but
affecting actual human beings mind
control but on mass that's kind of
interesting all right who's next
so everyone remembers spider-man far
from home right Mysterio maybe he's
still around you know the conviction
with which you just delivered your
thesis mister back thank you
yes Mysterio is coming back and he's
going to sort of use himself as a martyr
to create this whole media narrative
against spider-man and I guess it's
essentially kind of like cyberbullying
started this idea though that he is the
martyr spider-man has killed me yeah now
avenge me world or something so you're
taking the post-credits and just and
pushing it further
cuz he's like the master Mysterio is the
master of media manipulation oh yeah so
did he like many ads so did he like deep
fake himself in that video was it like
someone not was it a different person
that looked like him that got shot in
the head he I mean he could definitely
do that he's also conscious of illusions
yeah there's a youtubers I could pull
this off oh yeah totally so so what's
his plan then his plan is he's going to
bully spider-man out of just like
I guess out of the media spotlight like
ease the public is gonna turn against
him essentially by by Mysterio creating
this narrative and maybe you start
setting some stuff up for like sinister
six just casually throw maybe six so
okay so you are saying that he gets the
public to turn on on spider-man maybe
does that and first act even since we
already started that with the
post-credits scene then we deal with the
sinister six yeah because if he turns
the public on spider-man it's sort of
turning the public against Avengers in
all them so now it's gonna be setting up
for the whole sinister six is maybe like
a new new hero better than the Avengers
oh they're they're revealed as good guys
a good good guy team the same way
Mysterio trip and he's just gonna
completely do this Mysterio well through
manipulation of the media real quick
who's who's one other person on your
sinister sixteen Jason Momoa as himself
Oh himself he could play yeah as Kraven
the hunter oh I saw that this fan art
recently if you want to put that up on
screen no that's a post Malone again my
system so you can assistant to your Rogi
of a quarter Rogi right there okay
alright it's a sweet little packaging
Tommy sweet Eric
Boyd okay you got it and he the villain
that I missed the most or one of the
villains that I think didn't get her
property was hella I think Cate
Blanchett was incredible in Thor
Ragnarok and search her brought her down
and I feel like I could teach is a
really good job with that movie but
didn't really get hella her true
potential as someone who could truly
wreak havoc she basically just took over
Asgard and it was shortly after
destroyed so she never really got rain
we should kill all of the supporting
cast of that movie in like five minutes
remembers anything I wasn't she was on
blind-spot on NBC so what I'm thinking
we have Thor our love and thunder coming
back great taiga what tt is gonna be
directing it and it's a big mystery what
the story's gonna be other than you know
Jane Foster is going to be the female
thorn what if what happened wind
searched her truck his huge sword
through Asgard and destroyed it it was
the whole play man right yeah destroys
the whole thing but like where does
hella go like there's kind of a flash of
green when she goes down she's kind of
gets wiped off a frame but like she's a
god a goddess of death like she should
have been able to withstand that blow
like when when they find Thor at the
beginning of infinity war he just kind
of floating through space still able to
breathe you know
so he'll read and breathe unfortunately
able to burrito when I think what we're
gonna see in Thor love and thunder is
hello reincarnated in Hell licking her
wounds HDL HDL plotting her next move
her dominion of death where we saw her
at the beginning of four Ragnarok and
she's gonna be plotting her next move
but where is Asgard now as guards not a
place it's a people frame of mind it's a
people and ton's burg Norway there's a
new Asgard there Valkyrie is now queen
of that place oh yeah so what if he'll
Hellas next move is to target the new
Asgard and strike a blow in Thor's heart
and what hurts him the most is if you
attack Midgard you attack earth that's
where Jane Foster is and maybe that's
what causes Jane Foster to rally yeah
but what is Hellas new form right so is
it just gonna be Cate Blanchett in there
antler form again yes please I'd be okay
with that it's gotta be something else
well we do know that like the marble VFX
guys in the artists have this whole
thing from Norse mythology and from the
Thor comics of the Midgard serpent and
it seems like what these are crazy
there's images from this there's art
from infinity war where originally
thought was going to pull Stormbreaker
from the heart of the Midgard serpent
corpse but clearly they want to bring in
this
guard serpent that's something that the
infinity war writers wanted and you can
imagine ty quit easy looking at the art
of they're like here's what you have
available fourth or eleventh under he's
like that please
yes yeah I want that giant huge serpent
what if hella takes the form of the
Midgard serpent and you have Cate
Blanchett's voice ringing out Smaug
style from wait the Midgard so Don as it
attacks no way you already have one Rogi
because I'm down with hella coming back
I really like the idea of her attacking
new Asgard I think that sets up a nice
like redemption for the Asgardians who
is right now our refugees but they're
supposed to be like badass warriors too
especially it gives Valkyrie a moment to
have a badass hot lady lady fight but in
order to get another Rogge here I need
to see you embody this snake that sounds
like Cate Blanchett sure but Wiggles
like and well like we'll see I guess mmm
on the table Stormbreaker from his heart
[Music]
have a new Lord holders Cate Blanchett
impression thick Todd likes what happens
when eric has his hands tied by this is
Eric in Myrtle Beach in 2007 Eric how
how probably won't use this how
ridiculous is it that we have enough of
the same like mind and some of the stuff
that we are both referencing Homer as a
sperm cell acting it out and I think
you're trying to get me to do my Smaug
impression we played a game of Street
one time where I had to try to
communicate Benedict Cumberbatch's mocap
Smaug with only with one motion by just
going like
but really what I was doing I was
foreshadowing my own future performance
what's gonna bring her down is Lady SIF
she's coming back in this one it's gonna
be Valkyrie Jane Foster Lady SIF all on
Cate Blanchett as a Midgard serpent
that's hot as hell you got too big Thor
just watches over Aeryn he's like he's
fighting a Christian Bale as gore the
god butcher on a cliff I also forgot
that that Cate Blanchet was a snake and
the thing you just said so in my head it
was hotter until I remembered snakes can
be sexy so does the serpent have the
headgear though oh I hope so I hope
snake antlers and she's gonna sprout
snake arms just to do the antler brush
back in an over coil background sounds
let's hear him back in the form of a
tweet heads up at Delta Airlines I flew
one of your planes today and it was
delayed and the miracle of flight does
not withstand my inconvenience of being
two hours late to where I was going even
though if I went by wagon it would take
me three days so Delta I want a refund I
want an apology and I want the head of
Florence the flight attendant at my door
tomorrow age of Ultron
all right great I think everyone
followed that thank you did the head of
other Florence understand her scene her
head is just ghost guts now plane and I
was thinking snakes - snakes on a plane
hmm okay Mysterio was back as a master
of media manipulation hashtag woke Peter
Parker is canceled yeah actually it's
probably Athena's and they're okay my
tweet is a clap back to a Bernie bro who
says that Elizabeth Warren is a snake
and instead of Heath it is hella clappy
I've seen you think you know snakes wait
till I attack tonsberg norway fjords in
my giant
guard serpent body but then people still
refuse to elect to the cow well that's
the context given great I like all of
these I'm gonna keep your your point
totals stable because I have to give one
some acknowledgement to somebody else
this whole idea came from our discord we
have a rogue theory channel on discord
and it came up on there about villains
coming back and I just want to share
with you guys what our favorite rogue
theory was from Carroll BDC Diva Karen
discord Carol she's wrong really active
on there her thing is it's got to be
kill monger comes back which is my
favorite answer and I'm glad not to be
ticket monger nope too late
alright so she's saying what if T'Challa
eventually gave in to told Sheree try to
save him and game actually proved that
what Conda needed to be involved in the
rest of the world which is what kill
monger wanted anyway so
T'Challa can't stay mad at him for
something he ended up being right about
also I that he is has been exposed to
the herb from Black Panther too so he
also maybe has a little bit of lunch
ebony or it could be exposed to it and
then also sure he has a lab that was
good enough to save vision and restore
Bucky and specifically not be used on
what's on war machines but they gave it
to Martin Freeman's character to you
yeah but she has this amazing amazing
lab so she could have saved kill monger
put him in stasis and then Cherie just
to be safe puts a neuro chip inside of
kill monger just to try to limit him and
that actually is what makes come on gore
still feel like he's chained and
actually makes them turn on them even
though they brought him back and then
just somebody else I just thought it was
cool had the idea that he actually does
not could say by them but rather he is
left in the sea and is discovered by
Namor and named Wars the one who not
only brings him back but he now gives
some super aquatic abilities and this is
the foreshadowed Society of the
earthquakes under the sea that is
referencing endgame that's right and
that actually kill monger now comes back
as this very powerful force that has all
kinds of powers and
this human force and it's an
introduction of Neymar which to be
supercool love it yeah so that's that
goes over there that runs some rugby
points on our discord and if you are a
patron you get our link to our discord
and there's people are playing rope
theory on there and now it's inspiring
this whole episode so go on there and
fight Carole for the throne yeah she
won't give it up easily that we're
coming for you Carole yeah you can also
play the game here oh never mind Carole
you as easy is cut it all out never mind
Carole you're good in my book could any
of the guys alright moving on
did you guys do any of you watch
Invisible Man yes good surprisingly good
it was really solid Tommy wake up can
you see me oh yeah guys it is a return
to the classic Universal Monsters and
you know there's some Easter eggs in the
movie that might show you like what the
visible man story has been done before
but the biggest difference in it is that
I actually flipped the perspective on
this film they made it about the victim
of the Invisible Man it's through her
perspective the entire movie and then
they kind of layered this this kind of
more modern issue over about kind of
abusive relationships and and kind of
this stalker culture gas sighting people
people feeling like they're entitled to
relationships cut which kind of the
insel thing a little bit but all that
stuff is there and it is channeled
through the lens of a monster film and
it I think that's why work so well on
both levels so there was gonna be the
dark university guys remember that yeah
I was gonna have like the mummy and
Frankenstein's monster and a Dracula
movie and then Tom Cruise's mummy came
out and killed 2spooky Tom Cruise I just
I really like him sometimes but there's
a mummy
yeah that's a mommy so so here's the
rumor here they actually are gonna kind
of bring back the energy of bringing
these characters on but maybe it might
be a little bit more like the DC
approach of you know what these movies
don't have to be connected so I don't
need to hear team-up ideas which is what
they were headed toward right now
they're doing one at
but it might all be through this kind of
Jordan Peele twisted lens kind of vibe
than Blum Houses inspire all in the same
universe but they're not working in
Congress with each other potentially but
I'm a little bit more like a black
mirror episode version so it's actually
about something a little bit else so I
want to hear from you guys these classic
movie monster villains they don't
necessarily have stable ones that are
the universal ones coming back in some
modern way a new version of telling
these stories spook me up all right I'm
gonna take Frankenstein classically the
story of Frankenstein was the scientist
we know Frankenstein's monster was
actual monster and it was this kind of
philosophical statement about what's the
difference between a monster and a man
and our men the real monsters and he was
made of inorganic or organic tissue that
was reanimated from stolen harvested
body parts from criminals and was
created to be this monster who was a
afraid of fire you know classically but
like he classically you committed murder
but by the end of it he was just kind of
like this brilliant creature who
believes that he's kind of a Superman
more than the normal mortal men but what
I want to do is let's make Frankenstein
an analogy for Criminal Justice
corruption all right so what if what if
we follow the story of this corrupt cop
not all cops are bad but everyone smile
yeah I get a bad one who did some really
horrible yes well what have you had the
story of this cop who has shot someone
who shouldn't have and he's got a
problem of like he's got some prejudices
and some bias and but in the shootout he
gets critically injured and we're in
this kind of like Robocop scenario where
like we can save him but we have to
strip away some of his humanity the way
they save him is by getting harvested
organs and body parts from former people
who were on death row who were
incarcerated they take their body parts
and they use those funds to rebuild him
it's which this would make sense in the
sense that if he needs a multiple organs
very quickly it's not going to be
through the traditional national medical
system where you get Heat's on a list or
something it
it's urgent and fast it's some sort of
weird black-market kind of he's in with
the warden and he's able to get these
body parts of people he's put behind
bars through some kind of corrupt things
maybe they were falsely accused or maybe
they were put away for too long
and well there's probably a whole system
that exists that is in real life there
probably is something with what do they
do with all the organs of the people on
death row when they when they kill them
they donate them to science they have
cadavers they do except they do and I
probably save the lives of the rich so
that's what this guy is now he's this
this compromised soul and this shattered
soul who is now having the souls of the
people he put away that are haunting him
through his different body parts and
he's living this tortured existence now
and it's in his perspective of this like
haunted person he's not a good guy he's
not someone we relate with as a
protagonist he's living this tortured
existence and maybe it's the family
members of people he's killed who it's
from their perspective and their and
it's shifting back and forth and and
he's now the monster but it's like the
way that like we don't necessarily
sympathize him but like it's inside the
mind and it's kind of the lesson he's
learning of the life he lived and
whether it was a good one he's afraid of
gunfire that's cool so it's like a
social commentary about the prison
system but also maybe health care right
he's not he has to go through in order
to get organs I mean Bernie Sanders said
it an organ for every American thank you
organ family just the same liver just
you keep it and replaced new liver and
whoever ate a new heart every three
years just so I can feel different
things yeah and dark I have a question
though for you Eric
yeah is Frankenstein a zombie I read the
monster Frankenstein's monster is he a
zombie I don't know if it'd be fair to
call him a zombie cuz zombie mythology
is specific to I don't think you see a
lot of body parts being stitched
together in some mythologies from like
biological means whereas Frankenstein's
mythology is he stitched together a body
that was not there before hand and
was lightning - yeah well so that may be
a helpful answers does his heart beat
yes okay so he is he has revived which I
was revived I died once true story and I
was resuscitated so he is as much a
zombie as I am I'm glad you're back
I think Frankenstein's monsters a zombie
I think he classifies it's the first at
one of the first zombies for that to
actually really like to enjoy okay you
got a rogue you four clearly asking a
question because you had your own answer
that you wanted you a question do you
think that Rankin Stein wears a size
thirty six thirty two gene okay than a
pant yes yeah the answer is yes yes feel
seen I do love it actually I do like
Frankenstein being built by the parts of
essentially who he's tortured and now
tortures him for a portrait existence
and he can't kill himself he doesn't die
so there's no fighting all right who's
next
speaking of scientists I've got a theory
here okay so I'm thinking you know
creature of the Black Lagoon I do know
it yes yeah classic so what if this was
a whole story maybe like like a
scientist was studying like the water
and the effects of the environment like
pollution sure you know we have like oil
spills people don't put stuff in new
orders okay so what if there was a
scientist in a story and they're
studying the waters and they get so
close to all of these pollutants that
they start to I don't know like oil and
all the trash and stuff starts to affect
the scientist and they turn into the
creature of the Black Lagoon
so and they like try to kill humanity
you know it's like the Joker origin but
he falls into a vat of [ __ ] and trash
and garbage and oil yeah
yeah let's say you're conceived so okay
so give me what is what's his goal this
this creature of the Black Lagoon is a
black lagoon the oil so because of this
it's okay because the creature I mean it
could be oil well like so I'm thinking
maybe there's like a tie so this is a
scientist very close to studying the
waters of pollutants the effects that
humanity is having on these waters in
the environment and slowly these
pollutants start to you know pollute
their mind yeah make it all metaphorical
- and so they you know maybe there's
some level of like insanity and this
creature starts to attack humans - yeah
to fight back what the executives some
oil executives some people have been
dumping in rivers yeah I love it
[Applause]
very cool so just like like a man
turning into a beast it's kind of a
Swamp Thing Thing was great but it's a
whole cattle but it's a whole commentary
around the environment yeah yes an
important message from an important
message can the creature make it a woman
just sounds interesting
mmm just a woman in Apollo trashing my
thing Tommy first of all those were
really well thought out ideas thanks to
contrast that let me know cos a mine is
a spin on the classic vampire tale
dragula drag drug you track direct
truculent dracula but in this case it
surrounds a late teenage boy who is uh
becomes a massive fan of this influencer
who's like a dan Bilzerian hell
copter speedboat you went to college
with dan Bilzerian guns cash ladies
type influencer and what we find out is
that this dan Bilzerian proxy is a bit
of a vampires as a dracula carries an
immortal but instead of blood influence
clout cloud his blood influences blood
cryptocurrency is blood for him you know
he just fuels off of the economics of
being an influencer and he uses his
platform to create the same way directly
uses mind control to get his to achieve
his goals he uses his platform streaming
Instagram social media to create a army
of loyal followers who will do whatever
he wants
I love it I know that you think that's
not well thought out but let me paint a
quick picture for you of the Instagram
husband right the famous role of there's
all these boxtrolls on Instagram all
these carefully made-up shots and then
they usually have just their husband
taking it these women are gaining these
this amazing flashy eternal life in
these pictures while draining the lives
of these husbands who are supposed to
just be enjoying their baby what I'm
talking about yes yes that's very a very
interesting take on it and then he also
can't go out in the Sun you know I
haven't decided if my take on Dracula is
Sun resistant or if he's just fun
persistent why whatever he wants just
like Dracula cuz he's got a private jet
and lighting is a part of it like they
can't go out in bad lighting stop
talking about this and start writing
this Tommy it's too real that's another
Rogi for 25% of the franchise yes that's
a deal
alright I want to hear all of these in a
tweet okay okay Frankenstein is a
crooked cop made up of the dead body
parts of the people he put away and
he'll never ever sleep again okay Drax
back and this time it's about the clout
influence more likes influence
okay the environment fights back
when pollution starts to pollute the
mind creature the Black Lagoon returns
nice yeah nice and concise yeah you had
to Ryan your own compliment guys these
are really good road question Thanks
all right guys in the Invisible Man the
lead character battles [ __ ] [ __ ] her
invisible ex what would you say to scare
off your invisible ex I want to get back
together I have recently started
following some Instagram models sure oh
wait I just understood you meant
following yeah I've been tracking get
out of here I will tell the story on
next episode of big question
you know what story I'm talking about so
it goes she was a Cirque de Soleil
performer guys new pictures of the
Batmobile could be upcoming Batman movie
just just came out a nude pictures not
wearing anything and I love this picture
actually it's really cool give me your
best impression of what the new
Batmobile is gonna sound like Knight
Rider
the engine yeah yeah what if it just did
like a series of like tire squeals that
could be like the Batman theme so like
you know like guys family had their
iphone returned to them two months after
dropping it in a lagoon at Disney World
and it still worked ad for Apple what
Disney character was most likely to
sneak a nude photo onto that phone hmm
Sebastian the crab because he's under
the sea
in darling it's better down where it's
wetter it is better where Twitter I was
gonna say Donald Duck because he's never
wearing pants oh yeah mm yeah one of
those Crocs tik-tok mm-hmm croc yeah
something system is let's do a roadie
total for four and a quarter okay all
right so our winner hey it's Tommy Tommy
doesn't usually but this is because
you're going away for a while you didn't
know that that's Tommy the open Tommy
first episode have to trade shirts all
right well we are back twelve seconds
later you're actually pretty good guys
look great as well you look like Jesus
and Jesus Christ Superstar it's touching
my knees easily we have a really really
exciting episode of the big question
coming out this week that's gonna deal
with the question of what was like the
creepy dark storyline that they had to
write out of Falcon Winter Soldier and
was it connected to coronavirus yeah and
then we can play you boss everywhere
everywhere yeah at me rock stars and on
discord yeah and walk in Street to
Burbank and night yeah Tommy you can
find me at Tommy Bechtold and you can
find me in Arizona at Dodger spring
training this weekend also
congratulations Tommy the best extra
thank you thank you so much and thank
you for all the kind words honestly from
all of the people new rock star fans who
tweeted at me that was very nice of you
this will be the last sincere thing I
ever said he defeated Stanley for that
category best extra by giving a rousing
speech against the man
dug up his body suplexed him back into
his coffin and said greetings true
believers are you soap lexing me Tommy
we're gonna miss you in this life and on
this plane at Tommy Victor that's right
and then Gino's was for two weeks so you
come by just enjoy some delicious pie
and say hi to my friend guy okay
yeah that's right all right we're
checking out a sweet little diner in
East Hollywood that makes up Indian food
it's all coming up on diners drive-ins
and dives what is my shirt doing holding
my breasts in though this is nice can we
find you a tray on most social media
ayy tra E and I'm Angelica tre and also
just just for a quick reference if you
like she's just streaming of her life
and it's very fascinating to just watch
this girl live her life so if you want
to watch your streams other on Twitch
yes yeah okay so and that's a train a
train oh yeah go and then I filled
Melina and you can find me on Instagram
and Twitter and in a child's triple yes
well children made it for sure children
make everything I own I guys thank you
so much for going rogue with us and also
remember to join that patreon and
discord channel so that you can actually
go rogue with us in there and you'll
play the game - have a good one
[Music]